Rajapaksa vascular I believe that
neither do I must assume
responsibilities for his development
that we should not wait that outside
forces help with our development it is
through our work and our efforts that we
should go forward in path of development
and you can unique in social levels so
this is a video co-write Sabinas we have
this threat especially from Boko Haram
in Nigeria as well acne as acne al Qaeda
in the Islamic Maghreb and they also
come from Libya and these threats have
other causes poverty under development
and it is wise to face these threats we
must have a two-step solution first we
have to fight with weapons at the shin a
short term but in the long run the
solution is development so as to reduce
poverty because poverty is ideal ground
where terrorism is bread and this is
what we're trying to do right now a
short run around Lake Chad while
fighting boko haram within the context
of the multinational force that was
established with child Nigeria nature
and Benin but it will not be enough we
have to promote development can we give
up my leg chart area that's the best
response to terrorism terrorism has
nothing to do with Islam it is
what I'm to say because what the
terrorists will do a lock with Boko
Haram purple who Massacre slaughter
people rape women and academia in jail
has nothing to do with Islam the best
way to fight for Islam is to fight Boko
Haram logical not think that the
velocity in the future is follow
democracy not the one it is important
that everywhere in the world democratic
values must prevail shakti in each
country girl militia but also the world
its scale because you have to say that
now there is a shortage of democratic
governance in the world will give you an
example when decision was taken to
intervene in libya we were not consulted
it was a small group of countries which
decided to intervene in libya like today
we are paying the price for it so it is
important that democracy the American
values to be implemented everywhere in
each country also on a world level
you